how do you define and how do you suggest
others define success
some people success is retiring their
mom literally you know for you finances
inspiring people and educating them and
you know whatever they're peaking their
curiosity
um for other people it's just quitting
their job so you have to self-reflect on
what your definition of success is
because I think a lot of creators kind
of don't really think don't introspect
like they kind of want to keep getting
more and more subscribers kind of thing
and yeah but subscribers is just a
vanity metric you know it doesn't
subscribers don't correlate to views
sure or views what yeah I know but
that's more that was a drag to you that
was more direct to people listening
because uh a lot of people do really
care about subscribers or even followers
like on Tick Tock but if you look like
your view if on YouTube very very few
percent if even a percent of your views
come from the sub feed right you know
they're almost all home feeders
suggested what's the last time you
clicked on your sub feed to watch a
video oh almost never yeah yeah maybe
five years ago it used to be a thing
it's not anymore no one does
um and it's getting harder and harder to
find subscribe to way too many channels
I think yeah that's what everyone does
and you subscribe to 10 channels they're
great but two years later your taste
evolves and it's like it's a mess and so
um subscribers don't really matter
followers on Tick Tock don't really
matter
um so anyways it really they really are
the definition of a vanity metric and
but what about views they do obviously
because if people are showing up time
and time again that's what matters okay
so that
that's a good thing to uh Define a
success I just feel like um that too can
be a problem
because uh
I would say
you know if I wanted to be successful
like I said a young Creator I might
start copying Mr Beast or something like
that right yeah like there's you start
trying to take shortcuts as opposed to
find your your own unique voice right so
like chasing views is a problem too it
feels like or no
um it's as long as you detach yourself
from that I mean if you're
if you're lazy yeah and you just want to
copy someone else and not experiment and
find your own way but yeah I mean you
can't make that excuse for them and
someone just
isn't coming up with original stuff and
putting in the effort you can't just say
oh it's because they're chasing views we
need some different metric from the
chase no they just need to find their
own way well it just feels like a unique
type of content will often lead to
sacrifice in the number of views in the
short term by the long term you win
okay or if you do win you you win more I
guess would be a better way putting it